Hi, I'm Glenn,
from Android Audio.
I like putting stuff together,
especially music and software.
Today, I want to
share some cool tricks
I've been learning
about audio formats.
For most of our
careers, we've been
told to use integer, or fixed
point arithmetic for audio.
There's some good reasons
why we all use integers.
They're great.
Fixed point, too.
From digital to
analog converters,
to CDs to USB audio, integers
and fixed point are everywhere.
As we all know, hackers avoid
Floats as much as we do basic.
So let's review the reasons why
we don't use floating point.
First of all, it's not there.
No affordable
floating point unit.
This was my first FPU.
5,000 flops, and so
expensive, we only
used it when we
absolutely had two.
Floats are way big.
Four bytes each.
OK, this is just gross.
But you get the idea.
Floats are huge.
This one is my favorite.
The decadence of
Rome, I mean Floats.
Even if you have the CPU and
memory for floating point,
it's just sinful to waste
resources so extravagantly,
on something that's
clearly a luxury.
It's kind of like
using a 32-bit, um--
I mean 64-bit ant to
represent a Boolean.
You do realize this is
what actually happens now?
So, Floats are clearly out.
Or so we think.
Now, what do we really want
from our numbers in audio?
Wide dynamic range for soft
and loud, consistent accuracy
across that range,
and lots of headroom.
No clipping.
So let's examine our friends.
Integer and fixed point.
First, integer.
This is simple.
Adjacent values differ by one.
Integers are represented
in two's complement binary.
Fixed point is the same,
with an implied binary point.
For audio, the
implied binary point
is almost always at the left
of the most significant bit.
And adjacent values differ
by a constant power of two.
It's still two's
complement binary.
Now earlier, we thought
Floats work out.
But are they really?
Let's look at them
anyway-- don't worry,
it's just to make fun of them.
Or maybe not?
Floating point starts with
a fixed point mantissa.
The number of bits
in the mantissa
determines the overall accuracy.
Then, we add an
integer exponent.
This increases the range.
The wider the exponent,
the more range.
There's a signed bit too, but
we'll ignore that for now.
Now, remember what
we all want in audio.
Wide dynamic range for soft
and loud, consistent accuracy
across that range, and lots of
headroom to prevent clipping.
Let's see how well
Float does on all three.
We'll start with dynamic range.
Here's the formula for a
Float, combining sine, mantissa
and exponent.
Turns out the exponent increases
the dynamic range dramatically,
compared to integer,
or fixed point.
How many db or bits you
need for content delivery
is controversial.
I'm not going there.
What is certain, is that a
wide dynamic range is useful
internally.
And Float provides that.
Now, let's look at accuracy.
Remember, adjacent integer
values differ by one,
and adjacent fixed point values
by a constant power of two.
Sounds good at first.
Within some fixed point, though
the differences are constant,
the ratios between
adjacent values
are not constant, for either
integer, or fixed point.
Whoah!
What's that going to do
to consistent accuracy?
We lose accuracy,
where we need it most.
Quiet signals.
In this graph, the
ratios approach two
as we get quieter,
instead of one.
And here's our ratio
chart for Float.
The ratios between
adjacent values
are now approximately
constant, and approach one.
The distances are logarithmic.
Notice the tighter
packing near zero.
This means consistent accuracy
across the full dynamic range.
So, soft and loud
both sound great.
Finally, let's look at Headroom.
Headroom is a safety zone, above
your nominal maximum level,
to help prevent clipping during
intermediate calculations,
and transience.
This is where floating
point really shines.
It's almost impossible
to clip samples
during intermediate
calculations,
because the range to
afloat is astronomical.
Maximize your headroom.
So, it's time to
think differently.
Those were some
compelling reasons
to consider floating point,
in your next audio app.
You don't need to be an
expert in numerical analysis
to use floating point.
But floating point
is not a panacea.
You do need to know the
gotchas, and there are a few.
Check out the
references at the end,
with some tips and
tricks that will
help you avoid the
most common problems.
So, I ask you to
consider floating point
in your next audio app.
And what about all those reasons
not to use floating point?
Now, you're probably
expecting me
to say those reasons
aren't valid anymore.
Uh uh.
Some of them are still true.
Especially the
moral depravity one.
But the benefits mean it's
time to hold our noses,
and consider floating
point anyway.
Be forewarned.
If you use floating
point, others
will try to shame you
during code reviews.
So, be prepared for glory.
Be proud.
Wear the scarlet
F, you'll do fine.
Make sure to check out this
link for more information.
I'm Glenn Kasten.
Thank you for watching.